according to employees at the Food and
Drug Administration an internal FDA
email as well claims that the Trump
administration is mandating that
televisions at the FDA be kept on Fox
News at all times reminds me Pat of that
famous line the beatings will continue
until morale improves here's a
screenshot of the email that was
reportedly sent good morning please
excuse me for sending this out to your
entire group but I was alerted by a
member in your group and I wanted to let
everyone know that the reason for the
change from CNN to Fox okay a little bit
of a grammar issue there but I'm reading
it as written the reason for the change
is that a decision from the current
administration administrative officials
has requested that all monitors under
our control on the white oak campus
display Fox News sorry for the
inconvenience but I am unable to change
any of the monitors to any other news
source at this time the white oak campus
that's referred to is the FDA
headquarters in Silver Spring Maryland
and according to FDA employees they used
to be allowed to watch whatever they
wanted CNN MSNBC whatever because you
know there are adults in a western
country but after the story broke an FDA
spokesperson responded with the
following quote there was no directive
or memorandum from the administration
that went out to employees about
broadcast news channels displaying on
monitors in common areas throughout the
FDA's white oak campus so it seems like
a denial of sorts but CBS News has been
able to confirm the authenticity of the
email and the fact that FDA employees
have indeed been complaining about not
being allowed to change the channels on
their own TVs The Wall Street Journal
and BuzzFeed
also spoke to FDA employees who said the
same thing yeah it's on Fox News and
we're not able to change it and the FDA
although they deny the content of the
email say that an email that that email
was indeed sent by the FDA's office of
facilities in response to complain by
employees so the FDA is
both confirming that the email is
authentic and that employees complained
but denying that it's a result of
anything that the Trump administration
has said it's a pretty glaring
contradiction and the spokesperson for
the FDA did not explain why there is
this obvious contradiction in what has
been confirmed and denied here right I
think it's one thing when Fox News is
the propaganda outlet for the Republican
Party yeah it's a whole nother thing
when there's state-run media and this is
the channel that you have to watch if
you're at the FDA
you know what occurred to me how
far-fetched do you think this is that
the White House did force the FDA to
keep the TV's on Fox News and then the
White House forced the FDA to make the
public statement denying it like is that
is that crazy am I going down a rabbit
hole perhaps I mean if you're able to
make one demands there you'd imagine you
can make the other it's just so strange
because it's not like Fox News is
talking specifically about drugs and
food around the clock yeah I thought to
myself maybe they could turn the
monitors off altogether but maybe not
change the channel but in some places
you can't like all the controls are
locked so maybe they could just like
pull the power cord out of the wall but
sometimes in those buildings you know
the power cord goes up into the ceiling
to a drop ceiling and you can't even get
to that I mean they may have no choice
here but to watch this then you're
defying the boss you know what you're up
says goes in that administration you
have to be able to control the volume
though okay right I mean we used to be
able to turn it down until it's on mute
or is it like mandated that it be
blaring also I would love to see the
order that sets the volume at level six
and driving all the FDA buildings have
to put Fox News a little it has to be at
least 85 decibels at any point in the
room minimum or whatever sound level
Donald Trump decides that he wants so
very strange stuff going on over at the
FDA today's episode of the David Pakman
show is made possible in part by Warby
Parker eyeglasses Warby Parker recently
did the right thing and ditched
advertising on right-wing conspiracy
website Breitbart pulling their ads off
and you can get the free five-day home
Tryon from Warby Parker check out their
glasses I use them when I'm not wearing
contact lenses I started with the free
at-home trial
they send you five pairs of glasses you
see which ones you like you send them
back and whichever one you pick they
will put your prescription in - I like
this because I can actually show the
glasses to other people and not have to
just decide on the spot like in an
eyeglass store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they start at just 95 bucks mine
cost that including lenses and for every
pair sold they give a pair to someone in
need so to try the five pairs and
support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS